is there advice you have for young
people
about career about life uh
in making their way in the world yes
the two things i i believe that i say to
a lot of talented young people first
um i i don't think you can predict
what is going to be well renumerated 20
years from now
don't pick a profession because you
think even though your parents might
tell you or something
do this and you'll make money you know
this is the scene in the graduate uh
where
guy tells dustin hoffman going to
plastics money and plastics
we don't know so many of my students now
have parents who are telling them
uh bright students you know go to the
business school that's what that's
what's going to set you up to make money
if you're passionate about business yes
but don't begin
by thinking you know what's going to be
hot 20 years from now
you don't know what's going to be hot
from 20 years ago all right 20 years
from now
what should you do this is advice number
one find what you're passionate about
because
if you're passionate about it you will
do good work in that area if you're
talented
and usually passion and talent overlap
and you'll find a way to get people to
pay you for it
i mean you do it really well people will
want to pay that that's where capitalism
works people will find it valuable
right whether it's violin playing right
or engineering
or poetry you will find you might not
become a billionaire that involves other
things
but you'll find a way to get people to
pay you for it and then the second thing
is um it's really important uh
at the very beginning of your career
even before you're in your
job right to start building your
networks but networks are not
just people you're on facebook with or
twitter with i mean
that's fine uh it's actually forming
relationships
and some of that can be mediated in the
digital world but i mean real
relationships
i like podcasts because i think they
actually open up that space i know a lot
of people can listen to a podcast
and find someone else who's listened to
that podcast and have a conversation
about a topic it opens up that space
build those relationships not with
people who you think will be powerful
but people you think
are interesting because they'll do
interesting things
and every successful person i know
at some level had a key moment where
they got where they are
because of someone they knew for some
other reason yeah who had that
connection so
use and spread your networks and make
them as diverse as possible find people
who
are of a different party have different
interests but are interesting to you
that's brilliant advice and some of the
on the on the passion side
i do find that um as somebody who has a
lot of passions
i i find the the second part to that
is commit committing yes that's true
which sucks
because life is finite and when you
commit
you say well i'm never going to be good
like when you choose one of your two
passions one of the two things you're
interested in
you're basically saying i'm i'm letting
go i'm saying
that's true that's true which is
actually what does it down your means
five
letting go that's exactly right yeah i
think that's exactly right i think
that's i think you do have to make
choices you do have to set priorities
i often laugh at students who tell me
they want to have like three majors
if you have three majors you have no
major right i mean so i do think you
have to make choices
i also think um it's important that
whatever you do
even if it's a small thing you do you
always do the best you can you always do
excellent work
my kids are tired of hearing me say this
at home but i believe everything you do
should be about excellence the best you
can do
if i'm going to wash the dishes i'm
going to be the best person washing the
dishes yeah
right if i'm going to write a book
review i'm going to make the best
possible
book review i can why because you
develop a culture
among about yourself which is about
excellence
yeah i was i was telling you offline
about all the kind of stuff google fiber
and cable installation all that stuff
i've been always a believer washing
dishes
people don't often believe me when i say
this i don't care what i do
i i'm i am with david foster wallace i'm
unbearable
there's so much joy for me i think for
everyone but okay let me just speak for
me
to be discovered in getting really good
at anything in fact getting good at
stuff that most people believe
is boring or menial labor or
uh you know impossible to be interesting
that's even more joyful to find the joy
within that in the excellent
it's the giro dreams of sushi making the
same freaking
sushi over and over and becoming a
master that that's that can be truly
joyful
there's a sense of pride and on the
pragmatic level
you never know when someone will spot
that and uh
intelligent people who perform at the
level of high excellence look for others
yeah and it radiates some kind of signal
it's weird
it wears what you're it's weird what
you're attracted to yourself
when you just focus on mastery and
pursuing excellence in something
like this is the cool thing uh about it
that's the joy i've
really truly experienced i didn't have
to do much work it's just cool people
kind of
i find myself in groups of cool people
like really people who are excited about
life who are passionate about life
there's a fire in their eyes that's uh
you know at the end of the day just
makes
life fun you know something and then
also money wise
at least in this society we're fortunate
to where if you do that kind of thing
money will find a way like i have the
great i say this that don't care about
money
you know i have to think about what that
means because some people criticize that
idea as like yeah
that must be nice to say that uh because
i
have for much many periods of my life
had very little money
but i think we live in a society where
not caring about money but just focusing
on your passions
if you're truly pursuing excellence
whatever that is money will find you
that's i guess the idea of the
capitalist system
and i think that the entrepreneurs i've
studied and had the chance to get to
know
and i'm sure you'd agree with this they
they do what they do because they're
passionate about the product
yeah they're not just in it to make
money in fact that's when they get into
trouble
yeah just trying to make money exactly
you